Speaker 1: One interesting thing, though, by the
way, did happen at this cyber symposium over the
weekend, and it happened when Steve Bannon and
Marjorie Taylor GREENE were on stage because
why not? And it's when Steve Bannon suggested
that Marjorie Taylor GREENE should be the next
speaker of the House of Representatives.
So here he is, laying out his grand plan
for Marjorie Taylor GREENE future. Take a look
here. And once we win the house, do we have a
better speaker of the House than MTG?
Unidentified: Look at that.
Speaker 1: That's a bridge. Are we going to
need her speaker of the House to take it to
the Democrats? All right, let's let's
let's remember something here, folks.
This is an individual, Marjorie
Taylor GREENE, who, before
being elected to the House of Representatives in
2020, had never held elected office in her life.
She is a first time, first term politician
that hasn't even served a full term yet.
That doesn't even have any committee
assignments and hasn't for over a year.
And Steve Bannon is out there saying she should
be the speaker of the House of Representatives.
Because nothing matters anymore at this point.
Everything is a joke. So sure, why not right now?
I'm sure once you get into the house, you're
going to find that most Republicans in there are
going to say no to that. And it's not because they
despise Marjorie Taylor GREENE, but it's because
they've paid their dues. It's. She hasn't.
She is still a freshman representative
that doesn't even serve on any committees.
Heck, even Lauren Boebert is on committees.
But not green. You have literally no power. You
can't even direct money back to your district
because of your behavior that got you
stripped of those committee assignments.
And Steve Bannon's out here saying she
should be the speaker of the House.
Now. I know right now that is a far fetched idea.
Right, folks? Four years from now. Maybe not.
Matt Gates has hinted. And making Jim Jordan
the speaker of the House, if Republicans
take back the House of Representatives. They
don't want McCarthy. They view him as weak.
And if these, you know kind of oddballs
you're Matt Gaetz isn't Jordan's and Greene's
and Gohmert's and those folks if they all band
together and possibly even expand their numbers
in this year's midterms, then yes, we could
be looking at a situation where the worst of
the worst becomes the Speaker of the House of
Representatives. They've made it clear. I mean,
Bannon made it clear they want the
worst people you could ever imagine
to be up there. And I don't think he's joking.
Even Mike Lindell is like a fighter whom true
patriot pull out. Oh, yeah, she's great. They
love her. The rest of America, not so much.
So let's assume for a second Republicans get
this, you know, horrible monkeys, Paul type wish
and they make her a speaker of the House. What
happens in two years after that? I think we would
see another blue wave kind of like we did in 2018,
because I think putting lunacy on display. Putting
arrogance instead of intelligence on display
for the Republican Party is a death sentence.
And most normal Republicans understand
that. You know, Kevin McCarthy knows that.
Dan Crenshaw knows that. I mean, it's so weird
that Crenshaw is being attacked as a rhino.
You know, he's a very extreme Republican, but
apparently still not extreme enough to not get
attacked as a rhino. We're living in a topsy
turvy world here, people. I don't understand
what is going on with this Republican Party.
All I know is that if you want to get ahead.
You've got to act like the most
ridiculous human being you ever have. And
that's kind of why Marjorie Taylor GREENE, of
course, showed up at Mike Lindell's weekend event.